[Aplausos]
tras 50 años de los le pena al frente de
la extrema derecha francesa el partido
agrupación nacional tiene un nuevo líder
por primera vez fuera de la familia
Jordan bardelá de 27 años se impuso a su
único rival tras haber sido suplente de
Marilyn durante su campaña presidencial
se enorgullece de ser su mano derecha
en realidad no hay jefe Ella es la líder
política Yo soy más bien como el general
del ejército Si se quiere entender así y
aunque es conocido por su despiada
ambición insiste en que el liderazgo de
su partido no es un reto de la dos veces
candidata a la presidencia sino una
forma de reforzar su candidatura
presidencial de 2027 creo que María
independiente debe ser candidata
presidencial ella lidera la oposición
mientras yo organizó las acciones del
partido en los próximos años después de
que su partido ganara un número récord
de escaños este año y de que ella misma
aumentara su porcentaje de votos en un
8% en las más recientes presidenciales
Este cambio de guardias todo menos Un
paso atrás para lepen el rival de la
vialió criticó a su oponente durante la
campaña y acusó de alentar a los grupos
supremacistas blancos expresó su temor
de lo que denominó nostalgia extremista
pudiera poner en peligro los años de
trabajo para normalizar al partido
despojándolo aunque solo sea para
algunos de la etiqueta racista todo en
un momento en el que el nivel de respeto
Se está perdiendo esta semana en el
parlamento un diputado participación
nacional interrumpió el discurso de un
colega negro con un comentario racista
el diputado en cuestión ha sido
sancionado con 15 días de suspensión y
tendrá medio salario durante dos meses
es el segundo legislador sancionado de
este modo desde la fundación de la
quinta república
[Aplausos]